eux aussi sont en quête du Graal mais
une pièce de monnaie suffit souvent à
leur bonheur on s'intéresse ce soir au
détectoriste et leur indispensable
détecteur de métaux un loisir parfois
assimilé à du pillage par les
archéologues eux sans défendent Hélène
chapelet a rencontré l'un de ses
chasseurs de trésors à lâcher sur un
droit
qu'est-ce que sur les oreilles
il se
balade rient en écoutant les sons
renvoyés par son détecteur de métaux ici
nous sommes sur les terres cultivés son
arrière-grand-père et dont il est
aujourd'hui le propriétaire
régulièrement il part à la recherche
d'indices laissées par ses ancêtres
on fait des découvertes après il y a des
pollutions 90% du temps c'est de la
dépôt mais il y a aussi des petites
Troyes qui sont intéressantes et après
ben c'est là on se pose la question
pourquoi c'est là j'ai une tente il m'a
dit ouais un jour tu sais en revenant de
l'église il fallait que j'aille garder
les vaches et ben j'avais pas emmené ma
chaîne en or et malheureusement j'ai
perdu et donc on se dit ça pourrait être
sympa de le retrouver après quelques
minutes à tourner dans le champ un
premier signal était mis par le
détecteur Pascal creuse sur une
quinzaine de centimètres ce jour-là
malheureusement pas de chaîne en or mais
une tige en ferraille c'est ce qu'il
appelle la dépollution
je pense que c'est
pour Pascal la détection c'est surtout
un moment de détente en plein air
l'occasion de faire le vide pourtant
cette activité est très encadrée
impossible d'aller creuser n'importe où
et sans autorisation
il est interdit d'aller sur les sites
archéologiques c'est quand même un
minimum
il est nécessaire d'avoir le
propriétaire l'autorisation du
propriétaire c'est aussi un minimum
contact avec la mairie obligatoire si
vous êtes sur un terrain communal alors
les objets que vous avez trouvé
appartiennent
aux propriétaires du terrain toujours
120000 français ça donnerait à la
détection de métaux une pratique qui
n'est toujours pas reconnue comme un
loisir et que l'État assimile à des
fouilles archéologiques sans
autorisation préfectorale interdiction
normalement de creuser en s'attend de
recherche Pascal à tout de même fait
quelques découvertes comme cette pièce
de la Révolution française frappée en